[Aplausos]
[Música]
buenas noches
mi nombre es peter tengo 47 años de edad
llevo una vida muy sedentaria nuevo
deporte tengo dos hijas que están
presentes fumo muchísimo una vida que no
tengo muchos sueños una vida bastante
gris
[Música]
buenas noches mi nombre es peter tengo
16 años de edad
soy maratonista practico mucho deporte
entreno tres a cuatro veces por semana
seguro escalo montañas
tengo muchos sueños soy presidente una
fundación y tengo muchas cosas todavía
por hacer pero te toca a vos que te deje
contar tus 47 años
como dije en una vida gris
un día fui al hospital para hacer un
chequeo médico tecris heridos colesterol
nada que hacía pensar algo difícil o
complicado
como fumaba muchísimo más de un paquete
por día el médico decidió hacer una
radiografía de tórax
después una tomografía computada ya los
pocos días me diagnosticaron al cáncer
de pulmón
fue un tiempo difícil riesgo quirúrgico
y a los pocos días me encontraba en el
quirófano principal del hospital alemán
yo recuerdo ese día
cuando estaba desnudo el cuerpo del
cuerpo y alma en el quirófano principal
pensé en mis dos hijas
ellas eran muy chiquitas todavía para
perder a su papá tenían 8 y 14 años
le pedí a dios
que me dé diez años más de vida ellas no
podrían perder a su papá
después de eso
me anestesiaron y fue la oscuridad total
de la nada misma
ese día terminó mi primera vida ahora
que tocamos
los primeros días del hospital fueron
muy complicados
es un diagnóstico difícil tuve mucho
miedo
voy a detectar un adenocarcinoma y me
extirparon medio pulmón izquierdo
detectando me muchas fallas por un
enfisema y bullas en mi pulmón derecho
por haber sido fumador tanto tiempo
tenemos una visión muy extraña del
cáncer de las enfermedades en general
las consideramos algo muy malo algo que
viene de afuera algo que debemos
combatir algo que son dos enemigos casi
todas las enfermedades vienen de afuera
son virus o bacterias
desde el hv una tuberculosis o una
simple gripe y nos protegemos
pero como hacemos con el cáncer el
cáncer lo generamos nosotros somos
nosotros mismos son nuestras células
como podemos luchar contra nosotros
mismos no podemos
yo recuerdo cuando vino unos últimos
días en el hospital vino el oncólogo a
ver me puso una mano sobre mi pierna y
me dijo peter esto es grave tenés que
cambiar de vida pero que es cambiar de
vida cómo podemos cambiar de vida
siempre miramos hacia afuera cambiamos
de amigo nos mudamos a un lugar donde
nadie los conoce cambiamos de trabajo
me hice muchas preguntas y la primera
pregunta es esa famosa que dice porque a
mí
pero no obtenemos las respuestas porque
no es la pregunta que deberíamos
hacernos es para que a mí
cuál es el camino cuál es la visión qué
es lo que esto que me está ocurriendo
tiene para decirme
al poco tiempo vino a visitarme mi
hermana de alemania y me invitó a ir a
mendoza
fuimos con un auto por la ruta 7 por
[ __ ] yo ya me sentía un poco
asfixiado por mi capacidad aeróbica
estábamos a 2300 metros y paramos en el
mirador del aconcagua en horcones
bajamos fuimos hasta el mirador
y encontré una tabla que decía aconcagua
hace mil 962 que es la altura de la
montaña y ve la montaña más maravillosa
que había visto en mi vida jamás había
pisado a una tampoco
levante el cartel y le dije a mi hermana
para ti sacarme una foto porque yo voy a
escalar el aconcagua
que me hubiesen dicho ustedes yo creo
que la mayoría hubiese dicho estás loco
te vas a morir zafaste un cáncer y te
vas a caer en la montaña muerto
pero mi hermana no me dijo eso mi
hermana me dijo guau qué buena idea
tendré que tener mucho tenemos que
averiguar qué se necesita
volvía a buenos aires me compré un plano
topográfico del aconcagua y lo puse en
la mitad de mi living lo veías todos los
días
buzz que todos los datos del aconcagua
estudie sus rutas me contacte con
personas que habían ido donde yo quería
ir y todas sus fotos leí todas sus
historias hay que hacerlo uno antes de
ir a buscarlo y eso hice
tenía que entrenar y empecé a entrenar
empecé a subir los 17 piso de las
escaleras donde vivía me animé a salir
todos los días a caminar y correr atrás
de la quinta presencial parecía un
hámster pero todos los días estaba dando
vueltas hasta mis amigos me llamaban
aconcagua
empecé a correr empecé a trotar me animé
a la constancia me anime al esfuerzo
me animé a subir los 17 pisos de donde
vivían todos los días cuando volvía a
casa y cada vez más rápido me animé a
correr carreras me animé a llegar último
en las carreras en una carrera llegué
después de 10 horas y había desmantelado
el arco de entrada fui al hotel a
pedirme verdad yo estaba feliz yo quería
mi medalla yo gané yo sé que primero
porque ellos solamente competía conmigo
con nadie más
y llegó el momento de ir al aconcagua
organice una expedición éramos 4
y fui a buscar esa montaña
que tanto amaba claro que antes había
hecho montañas de 2000 de 3000 de 4.000
metros jamás había alguna y me costó
mucho
me costó mucho aprendí a meditar en el
esfuerzo aprendí técnicas de respiración
para poder respirar en el esfuerzo bajo
condiciones muy difíciles y de mucho
frío inventé mantras
había un mantra que yo decía que cada
paso era el nombre de mi hija caro
sophie
sophie y así avanzaba y seguía y seguía
o contaba hasta cien volvía a pesar de
uno pero me tiene que acordar las
centenas
todo eso lo hacía para no generar
pensamientos negativos en mi cabeza esos
pensamientos que todos tenemos casi saca
cosas un [ __ ] porque no le quita otra
cosa
y sigue a 6000 metros
como dos noches muy complicadas muy
difíciles no estaba tan acostumbrado
todavía y decidí que ese día esa era mi
cumbre
me despejé por qué
el destino último que llega a la casa no
la cumbre
baje sano a casa y me despedí de mi
montaña
y decidí entonces que iba a correr a
correr carreras claro mi capacidad y
lógicas de un 60 por ciento no era lo
ideal y decidí correr una maratón
y tener seis meses muy duros casi todos
los días
y fui a correr la maratón me decían que
mi frecuencia cardíaca era muy muy alta
y tecla era muy difícil resistir en una
frecuencia cardíaca de 160 o 170 durante
tantas horas ahí estuve en el corredor h
y corrí corrí y corrí he corrido unas 4
horas 54 minutos sin parar en la
frecuencia cardíaca de casi 170
pasé por todos los estados de ánimos que
la vida tiene fui feliz lloré me enoje
conmigo y lo mejor que hice me contacte
con mi cuerpo le pedí a mis rodillas que
no duelan
en el kilómetro 41 había un arco que
decía todos ustedes son héroes
y me puse a llorar para que todo el
último kilómetro que toda mi vida y mis
hijas pasaron como una película de ante
mí o pase por debajo de las puertas de
brandenburgo y 300 metros después una
chica me puso la medalla de finisher
el abrazo que le dí parece que me quiere
casar con ella
y fue muy feliz
yo había pensado que me despedí del
aconcagua pero la con caguas no se había
despedido de mí todavía es la montaña en
la que decide no nosotros
me invitaron a participar de una
expedición donde iba a personas muy
especiales que a través del deporte
salvaron su vida
una persona no tenía piernas fue una
persona que era ciega de nacimiento
una abuela de 82 años
una persona que estuvo detenida 10 años
en prisión y se rehabilitó a través del
rugby
formamos un equipo increíble
no nos ayude pero aprendí que todos
somos uno aprendió el verdadero concepto
de la empatía
que no es ponerme en lugar del otro es
ser el otro
estuvimos dos días a 5.600 gestos de
altura y otros dos días arriba de seis
mil metros de altura porque las
condiciones de clima eran terribles ya
era a principios de marzo
no llegué a la cumbre de toda la
expedición sólo dos pudieron lograrlo
pero estamos todos felices porque todos
habíamos hecho cumbre con ellos
el día que se inició el descenso la
noche anterior hubo 30 grados bajo cero
sentí un dolor terrible en mi brazo
izquierdo
era el último en la expedición venía con
una guía en la retaguardia
yo no sabía que tenía pensaba que se me
había congelado el brazo no había
rescate y me dijeron si bajas no hay de
rescate tienes que bajar por tus medios
aplique todo lo que había aprendido
durante tantos años mi meditación y
respiración el aquí y el ahora contaba
de los pasos y así pasaron las horas y
horas y llegué después de 12 horas a
plaza de mulas a 4300 metros
con helicóptero fuimos hasta horcones
después nación a mendoza y mi brazo
seguía frío y dolía muchísimo llegué a
buenos aires y el brazo seguía frío y
fui a la clínica olivos
me revisaron y no tenía pulso radial
los médicos dijeron no entendemos como
no tenemos que aportar t el brazo y la
pierna izquierda había tenido la
trombosis en las subclavias y no tenía
creación sanguínea en el brazo y un
trombo me rompió una arteria y venegas o
el dedo gordo del pie de perdón de
urgencia
estuve 17 días internados 10 alternando
entre terapia intensiva y terapia
intermedia
y salir del hospital los médicos me
dijeron mis amigos mis hijas bueno te
tenés que despedir de las montañas no
podéis volver a condiciones de frío de
altura además estaba anticoagulado
pero yo les pregunto te podés despedir
de la pasión
te podés despedir del amor
te podés despedir de lo que hace latir
tu corazón y lo que es algo tu vida lo
que encontraste te podés despedir del
camino que sentís
yo no pude
salir del hospital
y volví a entrenar despacito suave
reconociendo mi cuerpo todavía estaba
anticoagulado tenía que tener mucho
cuidado con accidente para no exagerar
me
diez meses después y se cumbre del
kilimanjaro en tanzania en áfrica el
volcán más alto de áfrica de 5.895
metros imagínense lo feliz que fue
la pregunta como vimos antes la pregunta
correcta no es porque a mí eso viene del
ego es para que a mí
la vida es como una biblioteca vos
decidís que libros pones en el primer
instante pones el libro de la pérdida de
la enfermedad del desánimo de lo
negativo o eso existe en la vida lo
pones un poco más abajo y pones en el
medio de la biblioteca la pasión el amor
los sueños las ganas de vivir eso lo
decidís todas las mañanas cuando te
levantas y cuando abrir los ojos
empezamos a esta charla diciendo
hablando sobre las dos vidas que yo tuve
confusión
decía que todos tenemos dos vidas la
segunda empieza cuando nos damos cuenta
que tenemos una sola mi nombre es peter
y tengo 63 años de edad
[Aplausos]
[Música]